although rise of the Tomb Raider began  its lifespan on Xbox one last November  it now has a home on PC as well and  after spending several hours with  Crystal Dynamics title on its new  platform only minor differences were  apparent the lighting on PC is better  especially in dark environments where  shadows play across the walls and Lara  crawls through glacial caves textures  are slightly more detailed from the  footprints in Siberia snow to the leaves  in its ancient Valley and while the  framerate did stutter several times  during cutscene explosions and quick  camera cuts they weren't frequent enough  to mire the cinematic experience  rise of the Tomb Raider is still a  fantastic sequel with an engaging  narrative well-designed combat and  seamless pacing making it well worth the  experience for players on PC